oui c'est compliqué de gouverner on a
une menace qui est arrivé alors qu'elles
étaient complètement inconnus il ya un
an
il faut aussi regarder l'opposition sont
co c'est normal c'est son rôle et
heureusement dans une démocratie qu'on
n'est pas le doigt sur la couture du
pantalon à dire tout est bien parce que
sinon on n'avancera jamais c'est aussi
ça qu'il faut voir dans la dialectique
de l'opposition cela dit on a maintenant
un an de recul
vous savez moi j'ai encore en tête comme
tous les français le discours du prêt
dans le public nous sommes en guerre
c'était sa thématique
quelle serait sa rejoint d'ailleurs
votre préoccupation tout à l'heure si
vraiment nous étions en guerre dans une
guerre armée qu'elle serait ce pays qui
est en guerre ne trouve pas les moyens
de se défendre
on en reparle mais nous sommes dans une
drôle de guerre mais surtout nous
n'avons pas mis tous les moyens de notre
côté on nous disait qu'on nous dise que
c'est compliqué de former des personnels
qualifiés pour faire marcher des
libraires qu'on nous le dise
l'année dernière en disant peut pas le
faire dans l'urgence on peut le
comprendre mais qu'on nous le dise
un an après où monsieur le premier
ministre dans son interview la semaine
dernière dit on peut pas trouver des
lits drea en claquant des doigts
mais ça c'est plus entendable et en plus
alors je ne reviendrai pas son rapport
la cour des comptes qui montrent que
depuis maintenant pratiquement sept ans
on a bien mon pas accompagner le
vieillissement des populations mais rien
que là dessus et d'un rien là dessus on
est en train de se questionner pardonnez
moi on est en train de se questionner
sur la région parisienne où c'est en
train d'exploser ou précisément on est
peut-être bien à la porte de finalement
choisir les malades qu'on admet en
réanimation
or cette région a subi une baisse de son
nombre de restes de lits de réanimation
depuis un an elle en a moins
alors est-ce que ça c'est se préparer à
la jeune ne crois pas il faut pas être
naïf
oui nous avons des valeurs à défendre
oui il faut être fier de notre histoire
et porter ces valeurs d'universalité que
la france apportait à travers le monde
mais pour toujours et ça ne et porte
toujours bien évidemment prêt ça ne veut
pas dire à aucun moment qu'il ne faut
pas poser des bornes à la liberté d'agir
et de faire ça veut dire concrètement
que lorsque un syndicat étudiant ou une
association quelle qu'elle soit
décide de choisir le public et donc
d'interdire une partie du public à une
partie du pays l'entrée de la salle ça
n'est pas possible si c'est sur des
critères qui sont objectivement des
critères rassurer mais nan ça on ne peut
pas l'accepter
donc il faut une sanction je ne vous dis
pas qu'il faut aller jusqu'à la
dissolution parce que je suis d'accord
avec vous il faut aider des combats
d'idées
des libertés d'expression sinon
effectivement vous serez empêcher de
parler par le précédent vous avez
empêché de parler on connaît ce système
là mais par contre on ne peut pas être
naïf au point de croire que ce phénomène
là pourrait passer comme une lettre à la
poste sans qu'il y ait des sanctions il
faut sanctionner l'unef à un moment
donné